bismillah alhamdulillah assalamu alaykum
which means peace be unto you welcome to
another episode of the Deen show we're
here trying to help you understand Islam
and Muslims and we like to thank you for
coming to this program to learn the
truth we ask that you have an open mind
to be sincere with yourself to be
sincere with the Creator first and
foremost and this episode of the Deen
show is one once in awhile I will pick
certain emails I'd like to get to your
comments and suggestions I am NOT a
scholar but I like to sit with scholars
sit with students of knowledge sit with
people who are more knowledgeable than
myself so we can both benefit so please
the fit questions these questions that
will require someone with a bigger beard
and some extra knowledge of myself we're
going to save that for them now this
email in particular was one that really
touched my heart and my next guest we're
going to analyze this talk about it it's
a from a sister and I'm sure a lot of
you people some people who are really
not firm in the Deen we're making
mistakes day and night Allah is the most
forgiving the most merciful so we hope
that we can stop making these bad
decisions and we can get to submitting
ourselves more to our Creator and after
we read this we're going to analyze this
and try to give some advice the email
goes a little something like this
she says please could you help me out
I'm so upset I can't stop crying I don't
want to see my sister crying
I'm so upset stressed out I can't think
straight I'm 17 years old
I'd never drank I haven't smoked thank
God
however I've done something very bad she
started texting it starts with those
little things texting a guy and then she
hooked up with a guy I'm so bad she says
it just happened I'm not proud of it I
regret it I met this guy last year I
used to see him and I've done some
really bad things with him I know I'm so
bad I do ask a lot to forgive me I know
life is short and I don't want to go to
I got no future with this man and why do
I feel for him so much even so even even
though he showed me his true colors he
even said I don't love you anymore
I feel that the only way that I can get
true happiness is through Islam I'm not
practicing Islam as I should I've sinned
so much is there any hope for me she
asks brother please help me and that's
why we're bringing out our next guest to
talk about this we're in the real world
there are real issues that are going on
so we're going to try to reach out to
the sister and talk about this when we
come back on the Deen show love there's
only one
how mad is his messenger oh la la la
ah-hah there's only one but Jesus was
his messenger no I did that maybe it
maybe it's just to break the ice
assalamualaikum brother Michael Psilakis
are you doing very good under Allah it's
good to have you back here with us good
to be here again we want to get straight
down to the topic here a lot of people
got to see your last show hopefully if
they're keeping up with this series that
we do every week and they can visit the
Deen show calm and our brother no man
Ali Khan has his own area there you can
click and see all the shows that we've
done with his brother this sister she's
made a mistake we all make mistakes yes
we send by day and by night lost so
merciful he comes up our sins we don't
want her to lose hope you heard what I
just read just hooked up with some guy
you know and these women sometimes a
naive and the guys on the hunt and he
got what he wanted and now he's out we
don't want this to happen to another
sister and we don't want the brothers
doing these things also so we want to
just touch upon this so everybody can
benefit and show the right thing sure
first things first shamelessness or
Sasha as it's called in the Quran Sunnah
is one of the biggest problems and one
of the biggest sins that are mentioned
it's a grave matter it's a very serious
matter at the same time in the times in
which we live this is the most common
sin in my assessment this is the most
common sin after disrespect of parents
uh-huh that our youth are involved in
yeah
it starts with things through technology
like text messaging in facebook or
myspace or whatever pornography on the
internet and other sources and then it
moves on to the actual physical act of
of zina with Muslims and among
non-muslims and this is a prevalent
thing it's a serious serious problem
yeah dealing with this is a particularly
difficult issue because it's very close
to the heart for a lot of parents who
are hard
broken if their children are engaged in
something like this and a lot of times
of payers don't even know that a lot of
their kids are engaged in something like
this
but at the incheon level we'll talk
about its consequences in a bit but what
I want to share first is the the key
question that sister had in particular
is there hope for me mm-hmm Allah
commands us in the Quran not to lose
hope in him yeah and he speaks about
that ayah of Hope in the beginning with
a very interesting phrasing yeah hey
buddy
o my slaves alladhina Allah Allah and
forcing him those who have transgressed
and engaged in violations against their
own selves lattic not on iraq Mantegna
don't lose hope in the mercy of Allah in
allaha ya'muru by jamia no doubt it is
Allah who will cover up the sins will
forgive the sins all of them all
together this principle of Allah
forgiving before we talk about it more I
want to show you share with you another
side of this picture in Soto for God
this is surah number 25 Allah speaks
about the person who commits murder or
commits Xena Xena is the act of
fornication okay ELISA is about this
person in lemon table except what for
the one who repented and we have to talk
about what repentance really means well
Amana and revived their faith well I'm a
Dharma and Saudi hun and then engaged
continuously and rigorously in good
deeds so there are three things they
prepend revive their faith and acted
they were good after that
now hear this out fillet Caillou but
deal Allah who say yeah team hasanat
Allah says then for those people they're
mountain of evil deeds Allah will
replace them with a mountain of good
deeds so he will take your pile of Filth
and convert it into a pile of gold if
you can do just three things first thing
talk about repentance second thing
revive your Iman revive your faith
actually the Prophet tells us a la la la
la la la la posada marina yesterday
yahoo a movement a thief at the time
that he's engaged in theft is not a
believer
now as Dasani heinous neva home in a
fornicator at the time that they're
engaged in that act they're not they're
not a believer yeah they have to leave
that faith to do that yeah right so it's
a profound statement of the messenger
sallallaahu said oh this is why when
Allah talks about the way he says first
you repent from it but what you have to
get back now your faith well I'm gonna
revive your faith so you're not a
believer at that time not at that time
so if def catches you you're in some big
trouble or in doing was creating in this
the theologians talked about this at
different scales and they talked about
you know Iman be different from Islam
meaning you're still a Muslim but your
Iman is gone yeah because the word used
in the hadith is Yemen but there are
more Stern interpretations of that same
text to in any way in any case this
sister and many brothers and sisters
like her the first step really is
stopping it you have to stop all
communication you have to give this up
in its entirety if it is that you you
end up texting this person emailing this
person talking to this person when
you're alone then stop being alone if
you're that weak be around company go to
the Masjid and sit there go sit with
some other sisters go serve your parents
because that'll take the opportunity of
time that you had where you were falling
into sin it'll take that away but
sincerely repent sincerely get away from
this sin and if you're really sometimes
people are addicted they hate themselves
for their addictions but they're still
addicted you know like you know drug
addicts sometimes they hate drugs but
they still take them and then they hate
themselves more for it so the best thing
to do is to actually get out of that
cycle right so get out of the those
times and places and opportunities that
trigger this behavior get out of that
cycle get away from it all altogether
this is the first step you have to take
the reason you're drawn to this person
is this is the first person that you
actually emotionally attach yourself to
and Allah made women exceptionally
loving and compassionate and they're
unattached so this is a you know it's a
it's a strength that Allah gave women
but if it's used incorrectly or if it's
misused it becomes a weakness and in
this case in your case it's a weakness
so the man pray
the men prey off of that compassion
they'll be they'll be nice and kind and
Flowery words and they will you know
throw words that have emotional meaning
but they don't mean them because they
only have one agenda fulfilling their
desire and when that gender is fulfilled
she is nothing more than a piece of meat
to him that's used go get lost I don't
love you anymore I'd rather marry a
seeker let cetera et cetera yeah so you
know you already followed into this trap
and you already know that he's shown you
his true colors so what you have to do
now is get away entirely just completely
walk away from this make Toba spend your
time in learning about your religion
spend your time in worshipping Allah you
I know you've cried a lot but you need
to cry not because you're sad over that
guy you need to cry begging a lot of
forgive you you need to shed sincere
tears there's not enough tears you can
shed when begging Allah for forgiveness
Allah loves nothing more than the
sincere tears that the slave of Allah
sheds in begging forgiveness of him
these are precious to Allah Subhan Allah
tada
how about the we got some young men
there Muslim yeah and you know what
they're out there hustling they're
trying to hook up with the women and now
how do we give them advice to know that
they shouldn't be doing this
and ibc actually talked to some brothers
who are doing some good but he said
brother I I diss is a vice that I have I
just can't stop it's an addiction what
do we got to say this is this is a
variable a terrible addiction so
powerful that the messenger sallallaahu
is for them warned us the greatest
threat he feared for this Ummah for this
nation wasn't the threat of invading
armies or like you know massive weapons
of destruction what was the greatest
threat he said for the men of my Ummah I
fear women yeah this will be the
temptation this is where Shaitaan will
get you you will have the long beard
you'll be at the mustard for fudger
you'll be a good brother you memorizing
Quran doing good deeds but when it comes
to this one thing you can't help
yourself my advice and because I you
know I used to live on my own in New
York City and you know you can keep the
facade of a religious person and a good
person does good things and then have
this one thing that's kind of your vice
and you
you start telling yourself well at least
I know so much other good yeah so I have
this one bad thing Allah is going to
forgive I mean it's not that bad it's
bad but it's not really that bad you
know so you start justifying to yourself
Allah speaks about the people of tuk
Watts really I was baffled by this
passage in on Amron he speaks about the
people who enter paradise he speaks
about their good characteristics but
we're not here to talk about the good
characteristics in that same passage he
says when the Dena is a fellow fahisha
whenever these people committed an act
of shamelessness they looked at
something they shouldn't have
they touch something they shouldn't have
they went somewhere they shouldn't have
that was shamelessness they gave in to
their seduction their desires right
these people Allah says as soon as they
do the mournful psalm or they wronged
themselves in any other way what's the
first thing they did that called allaha
they immediately remembered Allah
immediately the first thing was
remembering Allah now think about this
when we disobey Allah how easy is it to
remember Allah at that time like if
somebody's stealing what they want to
remember Allah at that time know when
somebody's looking at something Quran
would they want to say a lot more stuff
for Allah at that time no they're so
ashamed of their behavior they don't
even want to mention Allah right so what
Allah is asking you to do what is
commanding the people of genda are
people who do make mistakes but as soon
as they fall into a trap
immediately they remember Allah and they
ask Allah to forgive their sin sincerely
ask for forgiveness and then this asking
for forgiveness we have to learn is not
just saying a stuff federal law you know
the phrase in Arabic and stuff federal
law which we learned in this one law I
seek the forgiveness of Allah right is
memorized and people just recite it over
and over stuff for a lot of stuff for a
lot of stuff for Allah but really what I
mean by that is you know if you insulted
your mother and you didn't even look at
her any time sorry yeah just like that
are you really sorry no there's an ad
there's a face there's an attitude
there's a feeling when you're really
embarrassed and humiliated and sorry so
that's what we have to be but as advice
two brothers who are fallen addicts to
this thing
what they definitely definitely need is
change of company that is most likely
their friends that have sucked them into
this environment or if they have good
friends that they're not spending enough
time with
so they need they're not strong enough
on their own they need to be with
somebody else they need to be around
better people people that will save them
rather than drag them further into
Hellfire
this is absolutely absolutely critical
no amount of knowledge will help you
sometimes you can have the whole Quran
memorized but you won't get help from
that sometimes the only thing is Allah
has helped and even the most strongest I
mean think of this example Yusuf are
they said I have a prophet of Allah a
prophet of Allah he's in that situation
beautiful woman is seducing him he's in
the room alone nobody else around and he
actually is scared of Allah but in
addition you know what he's scared of
himself the Quran quotes mama
uberta do not see I don't consider
myself innocent either I don't say that
I don't have desires he acknowledges his
human weakness this is the greatness of
use of hardness Saddam in the end as
Noble as ease as a prophet alayhi Salam
he's still a man and a man naturally has
desire for women so he asks Allah to
protect him after acknowledging his own
weakness a lot of times these brothers
they live with the facade this weak
shallow argument that brother I'm not
that weak I'm strong I can handle myself
yeah I'm just talking to her what do you
think I am some kind of pervert you know
just what they'll that's the mentality
I'm strong I can take it yeah you know
here you have one of the greatest
prophets this man can take imprisonment
he can handle being thrown in a well but
he can't handle that he asked Allah to
protect him from that Subhan Allah he
said prison is better for me than what
these women are calling me huh right
this is a very serious lesson we if you
don't have that firmness first
acknowledge your weakness and then
second make sure you have a change of
company get away from that environment
get away from things that lead you to
that he says ok brother you know what
the the person is saying okay well then
why did Allah put this in me why did the
Creator put this in me and now you know
I'm supposed to fight this is there it's
natural it is natural so natural little
s calls it natural uh-huh
Allah says the yearly nuts certain
things were beautified for people yeah
this is the ayah of things that were
beauty
fight for us hope Lucia a lot even an
Nisa love of desires fulfilled out of
women number one thing that was made
desirable for people nowadays you want
to buy a car half-naked woman standing
next to it in the ad
what does beer have to do with women
nothing but they want to sell it sell it
through women use women as objects right
the first desire that people have multi
multi-million dollar billion dollar
industry pornography selling what desire
of man for women that's what it's
selling right
prostitution desire for women all these
crimes come from what one thing that
obsession man has for women women right
Sohrab wish I had been an Nisa well
Bening later on in life you will desire
to have sons rather than daughters
unless as people love having sons
well karate in ptolemaida Dhabi what
from the piled up heaps of wealth out of
gold and silver meaning savings assets
big savings accounts right lots of lots
of assets to fall back on right and then
a good ride while hiding was however and
branded horses now we don't have branded
horses we have brand your horsepower but
it's the same thing well and I'm well
health cattle cattle refers to your
investments because cattle in the old
day was the investment that you do you
puts its career really what is your ego
and how the return on your investment
the crop that comes out of that
investment these are things that people
are obsessed with yeah and if you find
people now it is worldly people that are
not concerned with religion what are
they obsessed about look at what they're
doing either it's women desire or it's
money right or if their investment their
business right or if their card or right
it's a big thing right these are the
things that people are obsessed with
constantly unless as these things are
there they've been put inside of you but
then the question arises why right Allah
says beautifully that he came at our old
hyatt it dunya all of that is utility
things to enjoy a little bit in worldly
life
well Lahore in the host Alma AB and
Allah he has much better return than
this he has much better than this to
offer so if you think your desires are
being challenged by the beauty of this
women or this well for this house
imagine the one who created
saying I've got much better than this
right so actually these desires are
there to feel if you really believe in
the hereafter to make you help you
imagine man if this is so tempting here
I should be far more tempted by what he
has but this is only going to be done
for the one who believes in the unseen
every Muslim says they believe in the
unseen do they really believe in the
unseen do they really believe Allah has
something better to offer do they really
believe the house that Allah has for
them will have better specs better
square footage better Landscaping better
property value than what they're going
after in this world it's really it's not
just a thing you say and pass over it's
a state of mind to really believe that
there's something better intellect in
the next life right and this is what it
boils down to these desires have been
put in us to see in the end is your
belief in the next life and better
things in the next life stronger or
would you rather take this now to cap
this off Allah speaks about disbelievers
but this is a human condition all human
beings especially those are a weak Iman
may Allah protect us all from it or
nobody is susceptible from it no or safe
from it one of the things he tells us
very powerful is can level to hit Boone
and I Ajitha okay what this means is no
you people are in love of rushing the
thing huh you want to get things quickly
now the thing is just to put this in
perspective if you run a business right
and I'm trying to sell you something
you're trying to sell me something and I
say okay I'll buy it from you for a
hundred bucks but I'll pay you next
month okay I'll pay you 100 bucks but
next month another customer walks in and
says I'll pay you 90 bucks I'll pay you
cash right now you know what a good
businessman will take the hundred bucks
next month on the $90 cash right now
he'll take the $90 cash yeah why because
we need to love getting things
immediately we don't want to wait you
know in business and say time is money
that that attitude want to get
everything now so now here's the picture
a lot our Lord tells us I will give you
a house I will fulfill every last one of
your fantasies every last one of them
there is nothing in your imagination
that you desire that you will not get
everything you will get and more beyond
your
but it's not cash it's credit yeah if
you want that then you gotta wait you
can have some of this it's not like
you're denying the world it's not like
you can't get married or can't have
children you can't have good life in
this world too
you can have them but I'll put
restrictions on it for you but if you
want it unlimited live this restricted
life and I'll give you unlimited this is
the sales pitch from Allah on another
sales pitch from Shaitaan he says why
you gotta wait I get you this stuff
right now enjoy it live it up you're
young when is this going to come back
and when when the Shaitaan says this and
you forget that Allah is offering
eternal youth Allah is offering
never-ending life Allah is offering
desires to the to the end you forget all
of that all for what one weakness we
rush to things you can't wait well we
can't hold on almost out of time couple
more points briefly go over if the
person says look I'm going to have this
in paradise anyways I'm going to have
this good time and all these other
things that you mentioned what's the big
deal if I have it here if they say quick
take it I take your pick The Messenger
of Allah told assalam at dunya signal
min wujin metal coffered beautiful
phrase he says this world is the prison
of the believer and the paradise of the
disbeliever if you want to turn this
world into paradise then who are you
according to the messenger description
you don't really believe in the next you
might think you do you might say you do
but you really don't
the other thing just to add to this zu
inna al-ladhina Cafaro Al Hayat o dunya
listen to these words are so powerful
especially for believers in our time
yeah
worldly life was beautified for those
who disbelieved where the life is
beautiful but for who those who
disbelieved why yes haruna mean and
Medina Avenue and they will poke fun at
those who believe they will say you guys
are missing out on life look at you
people you gave up all this stuff you so
for what for some paradise or some and
they'll make fun of our paradise and
allows words came true they run after
dunya and they poke fun at the believers
for running after what the Asura
unless as well latina taco and those who
guarded themselves not look at the words
he didn't say those who believed he said
those who guarded themselves those who
feared the disobedience of Allah there
will be the ones who will be on top of
the disbelievers on the day of
resurrection on the day of standing so
the phrasing there is a taco which means
they had taqwa they protected themselves
they warded themselves off from these
temptations they're the ones who will
have the upper hand in the day on the
day of resurrection may Allah make all
of us from them I mean a couple more
points for the person to a they're
sincere they want to do what the Creator
wants them to do how did they vent this
what is the direction they should go to
let these urges out in the right way
that's pleasing to the creator and B
just in short because we got only a
couple more minutes and the person
what's waiting for him if he just
continues to persist doing what his
desires are leading him to do and not
doing it the right way
see if you Allah speaks about the one
who persists well I'll take three or
latter question first Allah says Balaam
and casaba say 'ya no but rather the one
who earned a sin a single sin he's doing
all this good stuff but there's this one
vise well I have thought to be healthy a
to who and his mistake surrounded him
that one mistake he just kept going back
over over over he wouldn't stop Allah
says Allah Aqaba not on fear Holly doon
those are the people of fire in it they
will remain this person that's being
described in this ayah is not someone
who good as all kinds of sins one sin
but what's the problem over and over and
over verses he does want let it go yeah
this sin has become his god yeah
basically he submitted to this God he
ate Amanita ha ha allahu allah who have
you seen the one whose desire has become
his inna the one he worships the one he
submits to the when he gives into he
will give up everything except at one
desire so then who are you giving in to
allah that desire right so it actually
becomes a form of [ __ ] which is why this
person earns ends up earning the
Hellfire as far as the advice is
concerned for those who are in this in
this cycle they're stuck in this rut and
they need to get out develop a
relationship with the Quran develop a
relationship with the Quran in the
la in the sauna have that relationship
why do I say that what does prayer have
to do with shamelessness a law tells us
in the salata doesn't have an infection
it would work beautifully he says no
doubt it is the prayer that prevents
from shamelessness and evil deeds so if
you're a person who prays but still does
shameless things that means you're not
really praying because if you were
really praying that it would prevent you
from shamelessness and evil deeds so
work on your prayer really mean besides
the good company thing I talked about
before really make a project a life
project I remember eyes know Quran study
its meaning know what you're reciting
when you're reciting in the salon Mary
when I get married I absolutely get
married absolutely good absolutely get
married get made ASAP get married
yesterday hey Seth and Mary for the
right reasons Mary you know the the
temptations will disappear yeah the she
won't look beautiful to you after a
couple of years you're just her wife now
the ride is over right so marry for the
right reasons if that's your reason for
getting married it's too shallow in
Charlottetown and Miriam you know
someone you find beautiful but also who
has beautiful character beautiful Dean
that'll make you a better person most
importantly that will raise righteous
children for you because those are your
assets with a lot that's your investment
with Allah may Allah make us all those
who have righteous children righteous
wives righteous husbands I almost ha
know what Allah protect us in our family
thank you very much everybody well first
come on Vikram and thank you for being
with us also everyone that is viewing us
from all around the globe if you don't
get to see us here in the local Chicago
area you can see all of our shows at the
Deen show com please take the advice
don't barter something that is temporary
for something that's permanent we should
strive to see our Lord in Paradise that
is what the believer he gets excited
about and then to be in a paradise where
there's things to delight and true peace
and happiness things that no eye has
seen no ear has heard things that you
can't even fathom and imagine this life
is not worth losing all that for and
we'll see you next time here on the Dean
show God willing insha'Allah until next
time a Salaam alaikum peace be unto you
the DVDs for dawa is allah has said in
the quran in surah now 16 125 will do
alasa be a little bigger bill hikmah to
invite all to the way of your lord with
wisdom beautiful preaching and reason
with them in ways that are best and this
is a great opportunity for you to take
up the obligation take up the call as
Allah has told you to do and share this
beautiful message with the world Islam
submission to the one God doesn't see
what everyone's talking about if you
find one contradiction it can't be from
God but the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best give up
for spring guidance I would never give
up spreading this message hope then you
take that necessary step you don't know
if you're gonna live till tomorrow so
you got to find that urgency to do the
right thing right now if you say that
you're not believe in Jesus you have
stepped outside of his name you cannot
be a Muslim is attended our faith to eat
scone Italy everybody sleeping I arise
and ask a lot of thinking may Omar you
see all our you know all the sins I do I
turn to you to figure my sin - mom I'm
you sinful slave you're my love alone
I'm the one runs away oh look I me